نووي تكتيكي مقابل النيتو الاسيوي هي اخر
التهديدات وايضا لاتهامات التي اطلقها
زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ اون الزعيم
الكوري وجه الدهمات للولايات المتحده
بتشكيل نسخه اسيويه من حلف الناتو يضم
الحلفتين الاساسيتين لها في المنطقه كوريا
الجنوبيه وايضا اليابان كتله عسكريه
مستقبليه يراها كم تهديدا على امن بلاده
لحلها سواء مضاعفه القدرات العسكريه
النوويه منها على وجه التحديد على حد وصفه
الدعوه للزياده في الترسانه النوويه
لكوريا الشماليه ضمت الانتاج الضخم لاسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه بالاضافه لصواريخ باليسيه
جديده عابره للقارات تنفذ ضربات انتقاميه
قرارات تخص السنه الجديده حدد فيها كم
خلال خطابه امام جلسه اللجنه المركزيه
للحزب الحاكم استراتيجيته والتوجه الرئيسي
لبلاده لتتخذه وضعيه الدفاع ضد ما هو
بمحاولات واشنطن وسيول لعزل كوريا
الشماليه وخنقها الا ان العام الجديد في
كوريا الشماليه يحل مع تهديدات نوويه
جديده ففي حال فشل الوضعيه الدفاعيه ستكون
مستعده لاداء مهمه اخرى غير دفاعيه على حد
وصفكهم
[موسيقى]